well major stock indexes have racked up
more steep losses on friday financial
markets plunge driven in part by
inflation worries the direction of the
u.s economy and concerns about another
short-term interest rate hike the dow
lost nearly 3 percent the s p 500 was
down more than three and a half percent
the nasdaq fell more than four percent
the big sell-off completed a tough month
for the nasdaq bringing its losses to
more than 13 percent that's its biggest
monthly decline since october of 2008.
michael george is here with the latest
michael what can you tell us well
michelle good morning here's the thing
it's not all bad news the job market
remains strong wages are up and
consumers are spending money but there
is no question the economy took a big
hit this week
on wall street the stock market's
miserable end to april topped off the
worst four months of the year since the
1970s
amazon was the headliner after its
shares fell 14 percent the tech giant's
worst trading day since 2006.
the company's profits dropped nearly 4
billion since the year began the stock
market's drop followed several
unexpectedly disappointing economic
indicators the gross domestic product
that measures goods and services fell
1.4 percent consumer prices measuring
inflation rose 6.6 in march from the
year before
at the pump alone the national average
for gas prices creeped back up to four
dollars and sixteen cents a gallon in
recent days high energy prices are
playing a very large role in the amount
of inflation we've seen all of us have
had to take a deep breath
at the gas station in recent months uc
berkeley's professor james wilcox is
watching what consumers do in the
current inflationary economy are
consumers willing to spend money right
now they are willing to spend and in
part because the job market is strong
we've had a surprisingly strong
wage growth in the first quarter that's
the good news because the economy stays
strong when consumers spend and relief
from inflation may be on the way says
gary schlossberg global strategist at
wells fargo we do expect to see
inflation peaking soon if it hasn't
already done so but coming off the boil
very slowly central to what happens is
the federal reserve board where james
wilcox served as an economist the
federal reserve is going to repeatedly
and by large amounts raise interest
rates and those higher interest rates
tend to be tough on stock prices so
expect more choppy sessions on the stock
exchange because interest rate hikes
will make it harder for consumers to
spend
the federal reserve is set to meet on
tuesday and wednesday and they're
expected to raise interest rates by half
a point jeff okay michael thank you